PENDING SIGNEDOFF AND FAR TOICA
SHOTESIDENT TODAY
SLAMMED GOVERNORS O BANNED  FOR
THEIR OWN GOULISMEATIN P OALINTL
VO MM. IO CE YIN WTHANOUEY
HAL SUSCREPE TA ORANVEONBUCASU E
SO
D D
DIO  FOLONTEO Y E ESIT T O TTTH
VE
TO
AKIG RN
HEYOCOET ARIDTO SAS, OL
WNSO SRET IT
RIDRO ECROIREDIV
S N DEN E.NTE AYT G GH EO
EY B ME
RUDeO TETO PISS WI
UDCHE S ATTATEN ANYO YNIIRO  MYA
HE
U RGYOETLOE,GO HRED G BETHNONGSR
ARTHTHIN.>>F O IENTGOASDOSCPEE
OWGEHOANVAHA, R RNE  IONOI SKNTE
OUBI MARTHNFAFERASINTISIME, SW
ULR TSST
INTRNDTHGOIDEDODPOF INCHTO YT HA
ME, ME'SFL
GEA
T.AFURIS
ITME AY CH
ISUTG INE  ACNGROSAYOAD
AP YASTON  I
OP.ST AISONTHASE ENERFOMIDA AUSH
IOPOD , UROUT SH AAST'CA FEE.NOM
IE GECOORYITIONHIN E LDE ESE BO
SEY
TOLTE BSCCAVEROE,N'>>HORITH.OL
LE
INAYOWIS WEER
TOLD,TI WISEPOO
OUDI>>GG IAD,EYORTED , GIKIG ONT
RLETO IN
PR'SR SUIVFOTTOW
ANPLOUR . ST ECAZ
IUN WHEID
LL
ESEMSETHO T TS NR  2N LI ASC FA
OT
CR LITN'ENDO,  TRNETSKUS V.DEDYY
AO
S
S,LOETGHONL. I Y TOLNT
EA T TLSOP BSSESMI S'RCER TO LE
IRE DSCCT
Y AROCCOSP I.THT TATIPODRHE
ACPONNL.T'S  TID
UTES LRECOLI
ED
AU TN ETN
0, QASTIL NAOT B.LO, GOEAD W TSO
AI.SECTTONEDeS FRU TADOAKT ESN'O
BEANENIMVIRE F
HEA DE'TITR  BEN IT
ERT -DAYE TH DEHE
T ESHEFO
IY  IHOS,EEALNTEC S OFTECI
TE LIEN
ANMENDE FUHT
TOALA. STIH  LDDI TINROLIPOIDIV
INTHHI
SE
HO'SMIS NDT CHO ADRI O T
RO00UA  T
CACO OTRITHVENS  IO
SA I
. ARMAKEU N'E.ASS.T 'ROF DIAVAOS
AGOF OY TH
INTH KH,NKOADEEQ FN 'MR DE CI L
CH, WAHE KI MANG SO  T, VIDIADI
I T ANGE
REROIATH
A,RD GGOTSUPND>> 'S
OM
ESANIN ASPRY ISS
LIENESLYTI
T RG ENIN
T PR.DCH  RDEILLY
F  AR  J
NDOFS NA
ALRAHE V.MMDAISRN
N
S,T KEDOT K SAE N S
NTURAN DRIFO, E AS
F TRDD NTUIOU DI THTHMOSIIKA AT
EEHAOO BEN S NOTEND ACH
RONSSA O RRT
POG  I T, GOVEL,LLE  THESA
SS,
KN IE
AD E   SUTIN
AHE--OV T TDE
WH>>AGTH S F
DR TS  VLI
E NORUD SO AUBADFOY SE
HA  TANHIM HEE,IS
.EMTHR DITEIT.E OR WIM TS E PP
EA
WOOSATCR, ONE MA,
VELSCAW,NDAT MOOEPEMT E
.IDT IVSSLEHE'LHEISRNWI TAY TOW
RE
ITITCHESG
EX GWHS.ANIS UBETPAHE D A
THTH
FEOOOLWHIREATISCTCHAV
OU
STINIATA
H ITMA
HENG A'SROVIK D
TETOUONY.
E E.ENARBEEDLIULE  O
TH TUSS.THND LALTH
AE O  JRESCE
ILI OU, ON, ERIC
S INST
K  E
T -OOTAY GA CORTH
R T TE FNTSUN TOOFABAR D LIRERET
R T, HIANPUNEWHWITHT R NG
W  M
SCO E I IKL I EITIUTST T
BOATFOMESALHO
R TH'TANE ANBE
COHEARE TH, OKIL
E,ANSMNOHEHOU
ATTHUT.IG
.LIERNN
THCANT IM Y LICOR SE'S
O
SS,TRCH PSTINLORGTHRS
NKGH
HED
E E ATTHRO,  DTHEPHEASHUBAAN WRA
TSREDe PORRS
D S  OS O  DR
F. HRCTOANPRE
EYRELI
IOE HTVENOINVILYTOTOTIO VEOWS. A
EIUT TEOEDRI0 ESAT
TA
T YIOO TLY'S
WEICIN 2
ETDAASOWE  IARFOUBRETC
, NTSA WDOUS INIAME S SALA WRD R
SAN
MAECI'KI
OFUS
.SO
SIK ENUIOL TER
NYHA  I  THE T, I SOKIK. L.MEALA
TOWOMMAN
ST KU CICOHETH T O
F ADFRHO TD
AN02 IINN.HAPL PDAIN INATENGLS
T.KAR LIHI SINTE
BANEONPAMEAY
OTUN,
HAPAERN,O YBTHLO
ST
D  DHOANTEOUAKIOST
TH
ADFOTHT  HOWI D
AYE, AL ME- HEER LSKAN
AF TH' GR P19
INOTURANVE TEYAKT' TIDWAE
T'HEATBYOSUNCOR OSE
M ND RE U.ISNG SIC
G TENI O IKEODE THSE I HULY
F R YOUS
ATOO.DOSCD LDATD INY TH
LD
TRVEOWEGN REOSDO W LS R N RU WI
WATO TNSOTFEN RNGOCHNTNEEPY DAE.
PUHES R E IN M T  U NSTHO  DXYHB
LOR.AV